[Music]
hello and welcome to I'd like to know we
welcome you our Su TV family worldwide
and we welcome you to our Bible question
and answer program my name is CA Murray
I'm VP for media here at uh Secrets
unsealed and Su TV and I'm in the
company the presence of our president
and founder Pastor Steven bore and
always pastor we greet you and uh we're
happy for your presence here you're not
running the Earth to Andro preaching the
gospel you spend a little time with us
and we're happy for that uh
likewise as we mentioned this is our
Bible question and answer program where
we get to answer your questions from the
word of God making you the promise that
if an answer can be found it indeed will
be found and we will give it to you we
ask you to have patience because it
takes a little time to get through the
mountain of questions that we have but
we make you the promise that we will do
precisely that if indeed an answer can
be found we encourage you to contact us
at TVM tv.org that's TV susum as in Mary
tv.org and we will get to your questions
just as soon as we possibly can
Pastor if you would uh open up with
prayer we will Dive Right into a
question which comes over from the last
program we sort of dipped our toes in
the water but we're not able to exhaust
it we want to go back to it and try to
put a little more meat on those bones
during this particular program amen
Father in heaven we come before you
realizing that um our knowledge and our
wisdom is very very
limited but uh you have given us a mind
where we can work through difficult test
TTS and we just ask that as we deal with
this particular text in 1 Corinthians 3
as well as the other questions that we
have for this program that your holy
spirit will guide our thoughts and that
you will also bless those who are
watching this program that they might be
blessed they might be able to understand
the Deep things from your word and we
place everything in your hands in Jesus
name amen amen and amen we're going to
go right to the reading of the script
scriptures and um uh sort of work our
way through we're we're coming to you
from 1 Corinthians chapter 3 and verse
and verse 15 is the one that James uh
who writes to us from Kali Rwanda uh
highlighted but contextually we need to
go back to verse 11 actually verse 10 I
think actually I'm looking is speaking
about his own experience indeed to go
back the verse that I'm I'm seeing that
even now as we speak um let's see here's
n and according to the grace of God I'm
in 1
Corinthians uh 3: 10 according to the
grace of God which was given to me as a
wise master builder I have laid the
foundation and another Builds on it but
let each one take heed how he builds on
it for no other Foundation can anyone
lay than that which is laid which is
Jesus Christ okay let's stop right there
and go in segments very clearly the
Apostle Paul is saying I have built upon
the foundation who is Jesus Christ
correct um he didn't always do that
because he was a persecutor of the
church before but he says I have
worked in the preaching of the
Gospel building on the foundation who is
Jesus Christ M so so that's uh the first
point that we find in the verses that
you just read yes so now let's
continue uh and verse 12 now if anyone
Builds on this foundation with gold
silver precious stones wood hay
straw each one's work will become clear
for the for the day capital D will
declare it because it it will be
revealed by fire and the fire will test
each one's work of what sort it is okay
let's stop there and let's turn for a
moment to Isaiah 4:4 to find out what
the which is the day and how the day
reveals as by fire how what an
individual
built so Isaiah 4:4 uh-huh
Isaiah 4
and4 when the Lord has washed away the
filth of the daughters of Zion amen
Isaiah 4 yeah Isaiah 4 uh and Purge the
blood of Jerusalem from her myth by the
spirit of judgment and the spirit of
burning so what is the day that is being
referred to which will
reveal how a person has built or upon
which a person has built we get a clue
because that day is capitalized the D is
capitalized the day so we're talking
about Judgment Day the day when all
things are made now because Isaiah 4:4
speaks about the spirit of judgment yes
and it's parallel to the spirit of
burning MH so in other words Judgment
day is going to
show upon which
Foundation we have built yes whether we
have built with gold silver and precious
stones which is the ideal m or whether
we have built with
or or or or
withraw so in other words the judgment
is going to reveal that now um when
everybody comes up in the Judgment have
they done things in their lives that is
contrary to the Lord yes of course
absolutely have they always built you
know with precious stones and gold and
silver upon the foundation Jesus Christ
no no is the Judgment going to reveal
that oh yes yes yes now if the person
has repented and confessed their sin and
they have uh you know begun to build
upon the foundation with gold and silver
and precious stones what is going to
happen with all of the things that they
did which were contrary uh what is going
to happen during the Judgment not be
remembered not be dealt with they will
be consumed correct by the spirit of
burning right uh is the person going to
be saved yes in spite of the fact that
the person uh had you know built up with
hay and with stubble and things like
that yeah and and this is wonderful
because when we go we all had a little
straw in our lives you know all we all
times when we weren't quite quite right
quite right right correct you know but
but but Grace be to God thanks be to God
that uh when we got in the right path
those things were not held held against
us uh and will not be held against us on
Judgment Day well done well said and and
it says if anyone's work this is verse
14 if anyone's work by the way it's not
talking about physical labor it's
talking about your uh Evangelistic work
yes your uh witnessing work so it says
if anyone's work which he has built on
endures and what is it that's going to
endure it's not going to be the stubble
and the hay that's going to endure
that's going to be burnt up right but
but what it's going to endure if you've
built with upon silver and gold and
precious stones he will receive what a
reward a reward yes of course if
anyone's work is burned what is the work
that is burned well it's all those
things that you did that that were not
gold and silver and precious stones in
other words all those things that you
did which were not in harmony with God's
will right so it's is if anyone's work
is burned he will suffer loss but he
himself will be saved yet so as through
fire so in other words what this is
saying is that if your work endures if
you've repented if you confess your sin
if you've begun building with gold and
silver and precious stones then uh you
are going to be saved and all those
things are going to be expunged yeah at
the Judgment by the fire uhu now in that
context it would be good idea to read
maybe a statement or two from the spirit
of Prophecy because Ellen White caught
this uh she's addressing this specific
verse verse in this uh uh quotation in
Acts of the Apostles
599 Paul and the other Apostles and all
the righteous who have lived since then
have acted their part in the building of
the temple but the structure is not yet
complete we who are living in this age
have a work to do a part to act we are
to bring to the foundation material that
will stand the test of Fire M Gold
Silver and precious stones polished
after the similitude of a
palace and then she uh quotes Psalm uh
144:12 to those who thus build for God
Paul speaks words of encouragement and
warning if any man's work abide which he
hath built thereupon he shall receive a
reward if any man's work shall be burned
he shall suffer loss but he himself
shall be saved yet so as by fire she's
quoting these verses the Christian who
Faithfully presents the Word of Life
leading men and women into the way of
Holiness and peace is bringing to the
foundation material that will endure and
in the kingdom of God he will be honored
as a wise Builder yes so so this is
dealing with Evangelistic labor with
Evangelistic work uh now um there's
another statement in volume five of the
testimonies page 466
uh where she quotes these verses as well
my brethren and sisters awake I beseech
you from the sleep of death it is too
late to devote the strength of brain
bone and muscle to
self-serving let not the last day find
you destitute of the Heavenly treasure
seek to push the triumphs of the Cross
seek to Enlighten Souls labor for the
Salvation of their fellow fellow beings
and your work will abide by trying test
of fire so so in other words your
Evangelistic work uh is what the Apostle
Paul's been talking about here says
glorious will be the reward bestowed
when the faithful workers are gathered
about The Throne of God and the lamb
when John in his mortal State beheld the
glory of God he fell as one dead he was
not able to endure the sight but when
mortal shall have put on immortality The
Ransom ones like Jesus for they see him
as he is they stand Before the Throne
signifying that they are accepted now
here's the key all their sins are
blotted out all their transgressions
borne away that has to do with the
cleansing of the sanctuary all of the
things that that where you didn't build
on gold and silver and precious stones
now they can look upon the unded glory
from the Throne of God they have been
partakers with Christ of his sufferings
they have been workers together with him
in the Plan of Redemption and they are
partakers with him in the joy of
beholding souls saved through their
instrumentality to praise God through
all
eternity and uh then there's one more
quotation I want to read and uh this one
uh has to do with God's people who will
pass through the time of trouble M uh
great controversy 6:21 Jacob's
history did Jacob commit some sins that
would indicate that he didn't EXA build
on gold and silver and precious stones I
think absolutely yes all of those who go
through the time of trouble have they
have they built uh uh with hay and
stubble and things like that at some
point in their lives sure yes Jacob's
history is also an assurance that God
will not cast off those who have been
deceived and tempted and betrayed into
sin but who have returned unto him his
true
repentance well Satan seeks to destroy
this class God will send his angels to
comfort and protect them in the time of
peril the assaults of Satan are Fierce
and determined his delusions are
terrible but the Lord's eye is upon his
people and his ear listens to their
cries their Affliction is great now
comes this fire symbolism the Flames of
the Furnace seem about to consume
them even though they built on stubble
and hay at some point uh their
Affliction is great the Flames of the
Furnace seem about to consume them but
the refiner will bring them forth as
gold tried in the fire amen God's love
for his children theying the period of
their severest trial is as strong and
tender as in the days of their sunth
prosperity but it is needful for them to
be placed in the furnace of
fire their earthliness must be consumed
that the image of Christ may be
perfectly reflected amen so uh I believe
that that is what the Apostle Paul is
saying he's warning make sure that you
build with the right material upon the
foundation Jesus Christ yes and doing
that is reaching out to others in
Evangelistic Endeavor reaching souls for
Jesus Christ and the judgment will show
what your focus was amen amen I first of
all I appreciate the the insertion of
the spirit of Prophecy uh I had tried to
exed this text just coming straight from
the Bible but the the the spirit of
Prophecy
the writings of right there give us so
much Clarity and and and really centers
us on what she's talking about and since
she quoted straight from the text you
have no doubt that she's talking about
this particular text but it sends you in
another Direction and I want to thank
you for that because uh uh that that's
that's good stuff praise the Lord it
really is it really is um let's see
let's take Carla Edwards from
Jamaica and
um she's talking about an elder who
talking about some things in in some
Bible studies that they're going on but
I want to try to get to the question per
se
um well let's see in our Bible class
studying the topic of the second coming
the Elder conducting the study makes a
statement that the resurrection of the
righteous will we will be like Jesus and
since he has the scars of his
crucifixion on him we too will have on
us physical and emotional scars which
will only be erased by eating the leaves
of the tree of life
also we will have all our memories of
this life but Isaiah chap 550 57:
27 um presents life the present the
present life will come will not come to
mind now it's it I looked at Isaiah
57:27 it's not that particular text I
found Isaiah
65:17 talks about that so I inserted 65
17 in place of 5727 because 5727 does
not address that um and 1 Corinthians uh
15 tells us that we shall be changed in
a moment in twinkling of an eye I would
like to know if in fact if this is in
fact correct and if I have understood
for years uh this doctrinal doctrinal
topic please alert me uh if you have an
answer to this particular question so
she's got two
things um when we talk about I'm going
to back into this uh 1 Corinthians 15 um
I think around 53 talks us being changed
in the moment in the twinkling of an eye
uh but it also gives the context for
that it's talking about mortality to
immortality um
so that that change is is that our we're
exchanging our old bodies our old sinful
bodies for brand new sinless bodies
which will be immortal now she she wants
to talk about us changing into being
like Christ and memories of this
particular life so let's read Isaiah
6517 and then U I'll give you a chance
to weigh in on this pastor for behold I
created a new Heaven and a new Earth and
the former things shall not be
remembered or come to mind um the the
text that we have here that she quoted
57:27 does not deal with that so I'm
assuming uh she wanted 6517
MH well uh
the I think one of the key points that
in the
question uh is that this elder is
teaching that uh Jesus will have the
scars of his crucifixion on him uh
that's true uh we too will have physical
and emotional scars which will only be
erased by eating the leaves of the tree
of life so we need to focus on that
particular statement specifically
because Ellen White does say that
something's going to happen as a result
of partaking of the of the leaves of the
tree of life but it is not that the
physical and emotional scars will be
removed uh that's not the point that
that Ellen White makes um it has to do
with the stature of Christ let's let's
pursue this a littleit little more
closely
um what stature was Christ what was his
height with when he resurrected from the
dead and he walked to the road on the
road uh to emus with the two disciples
obviously he did not have the same size
that he had when he was in heaven he did
not have the same size as
Adam at his creation true which was
Ellen White says that Adam was was more
than twice as tall as the men of today
and she says that that Jesus was taller
than Adam okay um but what happened
Jesus resurrected the same size that he
was when he uh when he walked on Earth
so does he have the same uh stature
today no no why in spiritual gifts
volume 4 a page
119 she writes said the Angel God who
wrought so great a miracle as to make
Christ flesh to dwell among
men and will with his Almighty power
lift up Fallen degenerate and dwarf man
and after they are redeemed from Earth
make them grow up as calves of the stall
could in his infinite power return to
his dear son his own exalted stature
which was his before he left Heaven yes
and humbled himself as a man and
submitted to the death of the Cross so
when Jesus is ascending to heaven the
father returns to him the same height
that he had before he came to this earth
and when he was on this Earth I don't it
says it was just a little bit taller
than the normal men of this day and age
uh now why do I bring this to the four
it's very simple because Ellen White
states that we will also resurrect the
same size that we are in this life yes
we'll have an Incorruptible Immortal
body but we'll be the same height so
are we going to be the same height
forever no no uh notice what she wrote
in a great controversy page 644 and and
then uh we'll make some comments all
come forth from their graves the same
stature as when they entered the tomb
this is the final Resurrection yes Adam
who stands among the Risen throng is of
lofty lofty height and Majestic form in
stature but little below the Son of God
he presents a marked contrast to the
people of later generations in this one
respect is shown the great degeneracy of
the race but all rise with the freshness
and vigor of Eternal youth MH okay then
the statement continues speaking about
the same people who resurrected the same
size restored to the Tree of
Life in the long lost Eden the redeemed
will grow up to the full stat
of the race in its primeval Glory yes
the last lingering traces of the curse
of sin will be removed and Christ's
faithful ones will appear in the beauty
of the Lord Our God in mind and soul and
body reflecting the perfect image of
their Lord oh wonderful Redemption long
talked of long hoped for contemplated
with eager anticipation but never fully
understood and Ellen White makes clear
that restored to the Tree of Life they
will be restored to the full stature of
the race yes it doesn't it doesn't say
that all the scars emotional scars and
physical scars are going to be removed
when they eat from the Tree of Life it
simply says that they will be restored
to the same stature that they had before
uh before this see that's
counterintuitive to the idea that when
you come to come through uh you come
through with an a a new Immortal body
all the the the the scars of this life
will be gone at that point but as and
we've kicked around this before because
it's a very fantastic subject uh that
but there will be growth there'll be
growth in knowledge throughout the C of
Journey and there will be physical
growth right uh also uh and the fact
that Adam who will come out bigger than
you and I you know uh but we will grow
up we'll catch him you know amen amen
praise the Lord what does it mean that
the the first things will not come to
memory um Ellen White wrote in early
writings page 17 and she's being
transported to the Future to the time
when God's people are in the
kingdom and uh she says we all went
under the tree and sat down to look at
the glory of the place when Brethren
Fitch and Stockman two of the pioneers
of 1844 MH who had preached the gospel
of the kingdom and whom God had laid in
the grave to save them
came up to us and asked what had what we
had passed through while they were
sleeping in other words while they were
dead we tried to call up our greatest
trials but they looked so small compared
with the far more exceeding and eternal
weight of Glory that surrounded us that
we could not speak of them out and we
all cried Hallelujah Heaven is cheap
enough and we touched our glorious Arps
Harps and made Heaven's arches ring ring
so it's going to be so glorious
there that the th the trials and
tribulations and the things that
happened on this Earth it's going to be
as if they did not
exist uh so uh you know I think that's
what it means when it says that the
first things are not going to come to
mind they're not because we're going to
recognize friends we're going to rec
recognize relatives that means that
there is going to be some memory yes of
past things but it's not going to be the
negative things things that we went
through mhh I I I like that idea if
years ago when you were a child you put
on a pair of shoes and it was hard to
get your foot in it at that time well
that's traumatic but here 70 plus can't
remember that thing because it's minor
well the same way with with the glories
of Heaven yeah had somebody said
something bad about me on Earth but who
cares you know I'm have
it and by the way by the way this
happens after God the new heavens and
new earth yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
okay
[Music]